i see this uh sound bite going around a
lot on the internet especially in the
manual swamp you know you hear guys
saying [ __ ] like
um oh you're the prize you know like men
are the prize but then you look at them
you know you click on their avatar and
you're like dude you're you're the
furthest thing from that right so yeah
you're not [ __ ] yeah you hate [ __ ] man
it's like you know
she will leave if you wait not after
that i'd add to that too you know they
they talk all this [ __ ] like they want
women to change i let me say for the
record i absolutely hope women do not
change
because you can take a woman
that's acting a certain way with man a
and give her to me and i will get the
absolute best version of that woman that
exists
and so they're talking all this [ __ ]
about women but they're not actually
doing the work
to actually line up with what women are
actually looking for so they blame it on
women and say women are trash and all
this other stuff i don't have women
problems women are absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful to me
i don't have it my frame's right
they either get get on the program or
they get the [ __ ] out they go they know
that so they stay
so
a lot of these a lot of these guys on
the internet i really think they have a
misrepresentation
of
how women work and they want to blame it
on women instead of doing doing what it
takes to get a woman to cater and be
and want to be the kind of woman for you
that that they actually you know want to
have in their life yeah yeah you just
can't say like you're the prize and not
be it i mean you can't like i can't go
outside and you know find a 20-year-old
breasted piece of [ __ ] car and say
you're a lamborghini
it doesn't right that way you can you
actually have to be the lady
and any woman that like you know you're
talking about like you know women should
respect man men should they should they
respect every man because if she
respects every man and if she respects
him she loves them right or if she
respects him she's probably gonna sleep
with him so if you just have a woman
that respects every man just for him
being a man and not for having to do any
kind of work really she's just a [ __ ]
isn't she
you know i want a woman that that
basically thinks all other men are [ __ ]
and she thinks i'm the [ __ ] man wants
to do everything for me
because i've done that work and it was
very painful and i should have went
bankrupt a bunch of times i was fat it
was painful i had to push through for i
just had my fourth shoulder surgery
you know so i'm fighting through it you
very obviously you have quite a history
of overcoming things to get where you
are to have be in the position to do
what you do drive the cars have the
business uh i don't know how god gave
you that [ __ ] beard but whatever uh
complain about that later but
man you have to do it
it's always guys with great hair that
want my beard
yeah
i cheated bro i cheated bro i had two
transplants i meant to tell you that
last time guys asked me that [ __ ] all
the time
and i don't i don't respond to it but
i'm not i'm not uh i'm not shy about it
um i did about 28 i got i think about 28
i was like oh i see this coming so i
jumped on well it worked for some guys
you know my understanding is if you
catch it early and you uh
and you have like thick enough hair then
it uh then it does work out for you but
uh yeah i mean
i had a good donor area you know that
yeah but
yeah um
you know
i
truly truly believe that you can take a
woman
that
acts a certain way now if they're too
far gone they're too far gone like i'm
not talking about women that are super
super feminist like there is a such
thing as a blueprint but within a range
you can take a woman that
could be moldable and get what you
desire out of that woman if you are in
fact the right man let me ask you this
question so
on a on a percentage basis you know
you're dealing with whatever like 10 100
whatever the number happens to be but on
a percentage basis what percentage of
women in north america because i mean
like you live in miami you know right
now but let's just say with most of the
women that you're dealing with do you
think are moldable you know to the point
where they will enter your frame and
comply
yeah once they are ones that you're
attracted to
yeah absolutely and what i will say
about miami i think miami la new york
big metropolitans are outliers
i i joke with sterling all the time that
i feel like they
they are like an all-star team of of
kind of like not the ideal girl
i think that if you go into america in
general and that's kind of like
when the young guys are watching fresh
and fit you have to you have to realize
that these are miami hoes
truly they're an all-star team of girls
from all over the country that are that
are pretty much
done for
but if you go to louisiana texas
you know
maybe upper florida all the other states
and even california just get out of that
one big metropolitan city
there's good women out there and i
always hate to hear guys talking [ __ ]
about women and it's not because i'm a
simp or anything like that i just know
for a [ __ ] fact that women will act
right if you if you
are that person you can get them in line
let them know where the boundaries are
and what you will or will not do and in
fact i find that it it turns women on
quite a bit
that's true can you speak with
conviction
what's um
what amount of um pushback are you
willing to take i mean like you know we
talked earlier about how how most women
will generally comply if you're a high
enough valued guy and they see you as
your best option i mean that's you know
we've talked about hypergamy for ages
you know beating it like a dead horse
but it's like essentially women want to
look up at a guy they want to be with a
giant they want to be with somebody that
they respect they want to like they look
into your future and they basically say
you know think themselves you know okay
this is a guy that's that's got you know
they start ticking off all the boxes
sort of stuff and then they start to
behave you know if you will right
you